a
[Música]
desde el pasado 28 de agosto el uso de
mascarilla en espacio público es
obligatorio en parís y en la gran corona
como ya lo es en varias otras ciudades
francesas quienes no cumplan con esta
obligación se exponen a una multa de 135
euros que puede aumentar a mil
quinientos euros en caso de reincidencia
una persona que reincide cuatro veces en
el mes puede incluso pagar con pena de
cárcel en la práctica esto no se está
realizando pues quieres controlar nos
llevan los antecedentes de los franceses
a mano lo cierto es que la multa
francesa es un poco más alta que la
media europea el país que más penaliza a
quienes no usan barbijos es italia el
que tuvo más muertos en la unión europea
a causa del cobit 19
allí la multa llega a 400 euros y puede
aumentar a 1500 en caso de reincidencia
en cambio el país que menos penaliza es
irlanda con una multa de apenas 25 euros
que puede doblarse a 50 euros en caso de
reincidencia el primer ministro francés
ha dicho que la única herramienta que
tiene los franceses para luchar contra
el nuevo brote de kobe 19 es el uso de
las mascarillas setecientas personas son
multadas en francia- diariamente
[Música]
en bélgica del uso de la mascarilla se
ha generalizado en las últimas semanas
especialmente en grandes ciudades como
bruselas o amberes se debe llevar desde
el momento que se salga a la calle pero
también en espacios cerrados como cines
o restaurantes si no se lleva la
mascarilla los ciudadanos podrían estar
sujetos a multas de hasta 250 euros una
sanción mucho mayor que en otros países
vecinos como en francia que es de 135
euros o en países bajos que es de 95 en
bruselas poco a poco se ha ido
generalizando este uso de la mascarilla
a medida que han ido aumentando los
casos primero su uso sólo empezó en el
transporte público pero poco a poco
especialmente a medida que ha ido
avanzando el verano se ha generalizado
en todos los espacios a pesar de que en
las últimas semanas está bajando la
incidencia del virus en bélgica ahora se
descarta que se deje de llevar la
mascarilla especialmente cuando no se
respeta la distancia de seguridad
a
frente al riesgo de un rebrote de
coronavirus en italia las autoridades
del país transalpino utilizan sanciones
cada vez más fuertes para obligar a los
ciudadanos a usar mascarillas y a
respetar las medidas de distanciamiento
social en lombardía la región del norte
del país más fuertemente golpeada por el
coronavirus es obligatorio usar
mascarillas inclusive al aire libre y
para los indisciplinados se prevé en
multas de hasta cuatro mil euros
sanciones que reflejan la preocupación
de las autoridades frente a una
tendencia al aumento progresivo del
contagio que se ha ido constatando en
las últimas semanas aquí en italia y que
podría poner en riesgo la reapertura de
escuelas colegios y universidades
prevista para el próximo 14 de
septiembre
[Música]